From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
这里是芝加哥 WBEZ 电台，节目是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Hey.
嘿。
How's it going?
近况如何？
How are you feeling today?
你今天感觉怎么样？
Yeah, it's a little chilly. I'm so excited, man. This is the day. Yeah, this is the day.
是啊，有点冷。老兄，我太兴奋了。就是今天。没错，就是今天。
In a big hall on a pier in Portland, Maine, walls of windows looking out on the water, Abdi Nor, wearing a royal blue three-piece suit, American flag tie, American flag pin on his lapel.
在缅因州波特兰市码头的一间大厅里，窗墙外对着大海，阿卜迪·诺尔身穿皇家蓝三件套西装，戴着美国国旗领带，翻领上别着一枚美国国旗徽章。
Hey, John.
嘿，约翰。
Look at you. [INAUDIBLE]
看看你这身打扮。[听不清]
Yes, yes, yes. I dressed up for this. I ordered this online. It arrived yesterday.
没错，没错，没错。我为此特意穿得隆重些。我是在网上订购的，昨天刚到。
Ooh, just in time.
喔，正好赶上。
So it's all the US flag.
所以这身全是美国国旗元素。
This was recorded three weeks ago. Abdi and 45 others from 25 countries were becoming US citizens. And just before the ceremony started, Abdi was told that he will be leading the entire group at the end in the Pledge of Allegiance.
这段录音是三周前录制的。阿卜迪和其他来自 25 个国家的 45 人正在成为美国公民。就在仪式开始前，阿卜迪被告知，他将在仪式最后带领整个小组宣读效忠誓词。
So John, let me see if I sound perfect.
约翰，让我试着念一遍，看发音准不准。
Yes.
好。
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States of America and to the republic for which it stands, one nation under God, indivisible, with liberty and justice for all.
我谨宣誓效忠美利坚合众国国旗，及其所代表的共和国，在上帝之下，国家统一，不可分割，人人享有自由与正义。
Yes.
很好。
Any pronunciation problem?
发音有什么问题吗？
Perfect, but slow down at the end.
很完美，但结尾读慢一点。
OK, yeah.
好的，没问题。
It's been a long journey to this moment for Abdi, starting in 2013. We did a whole episode of our show years ago, built around recordings that Abdi made during that difficult journey to America. And today, to commemorate his new status as our fellow citizen, we thought we would replay that story with some updates at the end.
对阿卜迪来说，通往这一刻的旅程始于 2013 年，历时漫长。几年前我们曾专门制作过一期节目，内容基于阿卜迪在通往美国那段艰难旅程中录制的音频。今天，为了纪念他成为我们的一员，我们决定重播那段故事，并在结尾处加入一些后续更新。
His odyssey began when he won something called the Diversity Visa Lottery, or the DV Lottery. If you've never heard of this, it sounds like the kind of thing that can't be real. But it's been around since the '90s, run by the United States government every year. The original idea of it was to get a more varied group of immigrants from a diversity of countries into our country.
他的奥德赛之旅始于他赢得了所谓的“多元化移民签证抽签”，即 DV 抽签。如果你从未听说过，这听起来简直像是不可能的事。但它自 90 年代起就存在了，由美国政府每年运行。它最初的设想是从不同国家引入更多样化的移民群体。
The Trump administration has cut some of the eligible countries from the list, but the lottery is still operating. Over 14 million people applied for the 2020 lottery, with over 80,000 winners. Back in 2013, Abdi found out he won in a cyber cafe in Kenya.
特朗普政府已将部分符合条件的国家从名单中剔除，但抽签仍在继续。超过 1400 万人申请了 2020 年的抽签，其中有 8 万多名获胜者。回到 2013 年，阿卜迪是在肯尼亚的一家网吧得知自己中奖的。
Abdi was a Somali refugee back then, living in Kenya. His next tape I'm going to play you was from those days, so you'll hear Abdi's American accent is not as good as it is now. He remembers the moment that he won this way. He sat down on his computer.
阿卜迪当时是一名住在肯尼亚的索马里难民。接下来我要播放的录音来自那时，你会听到阿卜迪当时的美国口音还没有现在这么好。他这样回忆自己中奖的时刻。他坐在电脑前。
I put my confirmation number. I put my date of birth, and then clicked Submit. There was a few seconds of silence. But then, you have been randomly selected.
我输入了确认号码。我输入了出生日期，然后点击提交。几秒钟的沉默。接着显示：你已被随机选中。
Everybody went nuts, lifted him up in the air in his chair. But Abdi didn't believe it. He asked his friends to put him down and started entering his information into the computer again and again.
所有人都疯了，连人带椅子把他抬了起来。但阿卜迪不相信。他让朋友们把他放下来，开始一遍又一遍地在电脑上重新输入他的信息。
It's the same answer, the same response. I put in same response. I realized I won. I walked out with these friends all shouting behind me, in front of me, holding my hands, shaking me. My heart was bumping. I was not holding myself together.
结果一样，回复也一样。我输入了，回复还是那样。我意识到我真的中了。我走出网吧，朋友们在我身后和身前欢呼，拉着我的手，摇晃着我。我的心跳个不停。我简直无法控制自己。
Moving to America seemed like a done deal. But he didn't know the half of it. Winning the lottery was especially a big deal for Abdi because really more than anybody he knew, Abdi had been obsessed with America since he was little. As a kid growing up in Mogadishu, Somalia, he'd go to the movies, which, in Mogadishu, just meant a TV perched on a table in a shack. And he would bring a pen and paper to watch American films so he could write down any words he didn't know and learn the language better.
移居美国看起来像是板上钉钉的事了。但他不知道后面还有一半的路程。赢得抽签对阿卜迪来说意义重大，因为比起他认识的任何人都更甚，阿卜迪从小就痴迷于美国。作为在索马里摩加迪沙长大的孩子，他会去看电影，那里的“电影”其实就是棚屋里桌上摆着的一台电视。他会带着纸笔去看美国电影，这样就能写下他不懂的单词，更好地学习语言。
He became known to people as the guy who could translate the movie for you. Stuff would happen on screen and everybody would turn to Abdi, who would shout out, "He says he's about to kill that guy." He pronounced his English like an American. That's why his accent is so amazing when you hear him, which led to his nickname that all his friends called him.
他成了人们口中那个“可以为你翻译电影的人”。屏幕上出现情节时，大家都会转向阿卜迪，他会大声喊道：“他说他要杀那个人。”他的英语发音像美国人一样。这就是为什么当你听到他说话时，他的口音如此惊人，这也引出了他朋友们给他的绰号。
Abdi the American-- that's my name. That's my nickname.
“美国人阿卜迪”——这就是我的名字。那是我的绰号。
And as he got older, he devoted himself to the goal of getting to America, not only studying English, but also teaching it. He did some radio stories in English. And you can totally understand why he'd want to leave his country, right? He grew up in Somalia. For years, there was no functioning government. It was rival warlords, and militias, and just anarchy, dangerous and violent. There were bombings and attacks from the terrorist group, Al-Shabaab, which is affiliated with Al-Qaeda.
随着年龄增长，他全身心投入到去美国的目标中，不仅学习英语，还教英语。他做过一些英语广播故事。你可以完全理解他为什么要离开自己的国家，对吧？他在索马里长大。多年来，那里没有正常运作的政府。只有敌对的军阀、民兵，简直是无政府状态，充满危险和暴力。恐怖组织“青年党”（与基地组织有关联）经常进行爆炸袭击。
Abdi says, for him, or really for any man in his 20s in Somalia, it's hard to stay out of the fight. You can't just be neutral and go about your life. He tells stories of Al-Shabaab members threatening him to join them, or else. At one checkpoint on the way to his mom's, they told him basically, next time you come through here, you better be one of us.
阿卜迪说，对他或者说对于任何 20 多岁的索马里男性来说，很难置身事外。你不能保持中立，过自己的生活。他讲述了青年党成员威胁他加入他们，否则后果自负的故事。在去他母亲那儿的路上，在一个检查站，他们基本上告诉他：下次你再经过这里，最好就是我们的人了。
So it was that, or join the government forces who were fighting Al-Shabaab. Or he could flee the country. You know those boats full of people trying to cross the Mediterranean to get to Europe, and sometimes they sink, and hundreds of people drown? Abdi knows people who've gone on those boats and on boats like them to escape to Yemen.
所以，要么加入他们，要么加入打击青年党的政府军。或者他可以逃离这个国家。你知道那些载满试图穿越地中海去欧洲的人的船只吗？有时船会沉没，数百人溺水身亡。阿卜迪认识一些坐这种船逃往也门的人。
Yes, I've lost three very good friends. And one of these friends had his child less than a year old with his wife. He knew how to swim, but he could not swim because his child was-- you know, he was trying to save his child and his wife. And then they were caught up in the sea and sharks. They were not the only ones who died there. 75 other Somalis were killed in that journey. And that has changed nothing about our decision. That doesn't scare us a lot at all. We know death is there.
是的，我失去了三个非常好的朋友。其中一个朋友带着不到一岁的孩子和妻子一起。他会游泳，但他游不动，因为他当时正试图救他的孩子和妻子。他们被困在海里，被鲨鱼袭击了。不仅他们死在那里，还有 75 名索马里人在那次旅程中丧生。但这并没有改变我们的决定。这根本吓不倒我们。我们知道死亡就在那里。
Several times, Abdi planned to take one of those boats. But he had trouble getting the money together. And eventually, his mom talked him out of it. So instead, he escaped across the border to Kenya. Somalia and Kenya are next to each other.
阿卜迪曾几次计划乘坐那种船。但他很难凑齐钱。最终，他母亲劝阻了他。因此，他改道穿过边境逃到了肯尼亚。索马里和肯尼亚是邻国。
Abdi moved to Nairobi, enrolled in a university, tried twice for a student visa to America, was denied both times. And if he hadn't gotten lucky that day in the cyber cafe, he said he would be looking again in getting on a boat.
阿卜迪搬到内罗毕，注册了一所大学，两次申请美国学生签证，都被拒绝了。他说，如果那天在网吧没有那么幸运，他会再次考虑坐船离开。
Yeah. If I had not won this green card lottery, that was one of my options. I was not afraid to do that. I'm looking for a life. And to get to that, I'll keep trying to the death.
是的。如果我没有赢得绿卡抽签，那就是我的选择之一。我不怕那样做。我在寻找一条出路。为了达成目标，我会坚持尝试，直到死亡。
The thing about the lottery, though, what Abdi learned is that it does not guarantee you a life in America. And in fact, it's just the first step. After you win, you have to wait more than a year. Then you show up at an American embassy for an interview.
关于抽签，阿卜迪学到的一点是，它并不能保证你在美国的生活。事实上，这仅仅是第一步。中奖后，你必须等待一年多。然后你需要去美国大使馆面试。
And you have to gather all kinds of paperwork to bring with you-- medical documents and school transcripts and a criminal background check. Everything has to be perfect, every I dotted. The tiniest mistake means that you can be denied for good. In fact, most years, over half the people who win the lottery never get their visas. They don't make it to America.
你必须收集各种文件随身携带——医疗证明、学校成绩单和犯罪记录证明。一切都必须完美，每个“i”都要点上点。最微小的错误都意味着你可能被彻底拒绝。事实上，大多数年份里，超过一半的抽签获胜者根本拿不到签证。他们无法到达美国。
And right away after winning the lottery, Abdi got a bad break. The police in Nairobi, Kenya, where he lived, started raiding houses, looking to round up all the Somalis like him and kick them out of the country. We have a very unusual, day by day record of what happened to Abdi, because a BBC reporter named Leo Hornak wanted to document this process and started calling Abdi every night. This is one of their very first recordings.
在赢得抽签后，阿卜迪很快就遭遇了打击。他在肯尼亚内罗毕的住所，警方开始突击搜查，试图逮捕所有像他一样的索马里人并将他们驱逐出境。我们有一份关于阿卜迪遭遇的非常详细的日常记录，因为一位名叫里奥·霍纳克的 BBC 记者想记录这个过程，并开始每晚给阿卜迪打电话。这是他们最初的录音之一。
Hey, Abdi. Can you hear me?
嘿，阿卜迪。听得见我吗？
Yeah, yeah, yeah. I can hear you.
听得见，听得见，听得见。
Are you safe right now, for the moment?
你现在安全吗？
Yeah. Actually, I'm safe.
是的。实际上，我很安全。
You sent me an email that had me really worried today. Tell me what happened.
你今天给我发了一封让我非常担心的邮件。告诉我发生了什么。
Yeah, it was crazy. I was actually chatting with some of the people in our apartment when these guys-- we don't call them the police, we call them the guys. Out of nowhere, they appeared at the gate. And they asked us all to raise our hands up. And you know, we were thinking, like, OK, this is the end of it. We're going to go there tonight.
简直疯了。我当时正和公寓里的一些人聊天，突然这些家伙——我们不称他们为警察，我们称他们为“那些家伙”。不知从哪儿冒出来，出现在大门口。他们要求我们全都举起手来。你知道，我们当时心想：完了，今晚我们要进去了。
By there, he means a place called Kasarani, a giant soccer stadium that Kenyan authorities and police were using as a makeshift jail to hold hundreds of refugees.
“进去”是指一个叫卡萨拉尼的地方，那是一个巨大的足球场，肯尼亚当局和警方将其用作临时的临时监狱，关押了数百名难民。
Like, oh, my god, the next couple of nights you're going to be spending there in the concentration camp. And then they take you to Mogadishu. And OK, you're going to miss your lottery. All that things were going through my mind.
心想：天哪，接下来的几晚要在集中营里度过了。然后他们会把你带回摩加迪沙。好吧，你的抽签就没戏了。所有这些念头都在我脑海里盘旋。
This call happened on April 17, 2014. Abdi had 96 days to go before his interview at the US embassy, which would be scheduled for July 22nd. Leo started calling him every day. He was worried for him. Like I say, over half the people who win this lottery never make it to the United States. Would Abdi succeed?
这次通话发生在 2014 年 4 月 17 日。距离阿卜迪 7 月 22 日在美国大使馆的面试还有 96 天。里奥开始每天给他打电话。他很为阿卜迪担心。就像我说的，超过一半的抽签获胜者从未到达过美国。阿卜迪会成功吗？
Over the next three months, he faced a horrifying obstacle course. It's just like one seemingly impossible task after another. At several points, he's afraid for his life. And his story is the story of so many people around the world who are desperately trying to make it to America, to become one of us.
在接下来的三个月里，他面临着一场可怕的障碍赛。就像一个看似不可能的任务接着另一个。有好几次，他都担心自己的生命安全。他的故事是全世界无数绝望地试图前往美国、成为我们其中一员的人们的故事。
OK, so you remember where we are. Abdi is about to be taken into custody by the police. Here's Leo Hornak.
好的，你还记得我们在哪里吧。阿卜迪即将被警方拘留。这是里奥·霍纳克。
So here's why the police were raiding Abdi's neighborhood in Nairobi. Al-Shabaab, the very group Abdi moved to Kenya to escape, had been ramping up terrorist attacks inside Kenya. You may remember one of the biggest ones.
这是警方在内罗毕突袭阿卜迪所在社区的原因。阿卜迪为了逃避而搬到肯尼亚的“青年党”，一直在肯尼亚境内加剧恐怖袭击。你可能还记得其中最严重的一次。
The hostage crisis in the upscale Westgate Mall is ongoing, the chaotic scene now a tense standoff.
高档的西门购物中心人质危机仍在持续，现场局势混乱，形成紧张对峙。
In September 2013, Al-Shabaab gunmen trapped hundreds of people in a mall for days and killed 67. And the way the Kenyan government responded to these terrorist attacks was the way governments often do in these situations-- with a huge crackdown on the community they held responsible. Al-Shabaab is from Somalia, so they go after Somali refugees living in Kenya.
2013 年 9 月，青年党武装分子将数百人困在购物中心数日，杀死了 67 人。肯尼亚政府对这些恐怖袭击的反应方式，是各国政府在类似情况下的常见做法——对他们认为负责的群体进行大规模打压。青年党来自索马里，所以他们针对居住在肯尼亚的索马里难民。
The government is trying to clear them out of Kenya's cities and move them to camps in the country, or deport them back to Somalia. And in Nairobi, the neighborhood they target is Abdi's neighborhood. It's called Eastleigh. It's a dense neighborhood where many poor Somalis live and where there's some Al-Shabaab support.
政府试图将他们从肯尼亚城市清理出去，转移到国内的难民营，或者驱逐回索马里。在内罗毕，他们针对的街区就是阿卜迪居住的地方。它叫东利（Eastleigh），这是一个密集的社区，住着许多贫困的索马里人，那里也存在一些对青年党的支持。
Eastleigh's been there for decades. It's known as "Little Mogadishu". Abdi lives there with his older brother, Hassan, in a small room with one bed and a single bathroom for the whole building. So back to that phone call on April 17th. The police show up and grab Abdi by the shirt.
东利已经存在几十年了。它被称为“小摩加迪沙”。阿卜迪和他的哥哥哈桑住在一个小房间里，只有一张床，整栋楼共用一个卫生间。回到 4 月 17 日的那个电话，警察出现并揪住阿卜迪的衣领。
They just get your collar and hold it so tight. And they tell you, come with me and just get into the truck. That's what they said to all of us.
他们就是抓住你的领子，勒得紧紧的。他们告诉你：跟我来，上卡车。他们对我们所有人都是这么说的。
It's 96 days until Abdi's interview. And Abdi's worried they're going to throw him and his brother into a truck and take them into detention, before he can ever get his papers together and leave for America.
距离阿卜迪的面试还有 96 天。阿卜迪很担心他们会把他和哥哥扔进卡车关押起来，让他无法准备好文件去美国。
They threaten you, and they try to forcibly take you to the trucks. We were not going with them. We were saying, OK, let's negotiate. I'm not going anywhere. I have legitimate documents. And they were telling us, OK, bring out all your documents. What do you have?
他们威胁你，试图强行把你带上车。我们没有跟他们走。我们说：好吧，我们协商一下。我哪儿也不去。我有合法的证件。他们对我们说：行，把你们所有的证件都拿出来。你们有什么？
Abdi pulls out his refugee ID. Officially, that should protect Abdi. It's from the United Nations. Unofficially--
阿卜迪拿出了他的难民身份证。按理说，那应该能保护阿卜迪。它是联合国的证件。但实际上——
He didn't even try to give it a single glance, because he knows the shape. He knows the frame of it. And he says-- he threw it into my face and he says, you're a refugee. What are you doing here? And they were like, come on, give us whatever you have. That's one of them said.
他连看都不看一眼，因为他认得那个形状。他知道它的规格。他把它扔到我脸上说：你是难民。你在这里干什么？他们说：快点，把你们有的东西都交出来。其中一个人这样说。
So that's when the real business starts.
于是，真正的生意开始了。
Yeah, when the real business starts.
是的，当真正的“生意”开始。
AKA, the bribes. Abdi, his brother, and the neighbors start pooling their cash.
也就是贿赂。阿卜迪、他哥哥和邻居们开始凑钱。
In total, I think we give them more than $80 US. And I had to beg them. Please, I have nothing. This is all I have. I have nothing. I have nothing. This is all I have. Please, you have to take it.
总共我想我们给了他们超过 80 美元。我不得不哀求他们：拜托，我什么都没有。这是我仅有的。我什么都没有，我什么都没有。这是我所有的钱了。拜托，你一定要收下。
And how much does $80 US buy you in Eastleigh?
在东利，80 美元能买到什么？
It gives you the best food. It's better off jeans, better off shirts, jacket, all that stuff. It's a lot of money. It's indeed a lot of money.
它能让你吃上最好的食物。能买到更好的牛仔裤、衬衫、夹克，诸如此类的。这是一大笔钱。这确实是一大笔钱。
And Abdi, what happens next? I mean, there's no solution, right, to this. This could happen again tomorrow.
那接下来会发生什么呢？我的意思是，这没有解决方案，对吧？这种情况明天还会发生。
Not even tomorrow. It can happen right now. It can happen tonight. It can happen the next few minutes. It can happen in the next few hours.
甚至不用等到明天。现在就会发生。今晚就会发生。接下来的几分钟就会发生。接下来的几小时就会发生。
Talking to Abdi every day, what I realized was how relentless it is. Every night's another excuse for a crackdown. And the Somalis are sitting ducks, trapped in this one neighborhood.
每天和阿卜迪交谈，我意识到这是多么无情。每天晚上都是突袭的借口。而索马里人就是待宰的羔羊，困在这一个街区里。
Most people are indoors today. They're not going to anywhere. They're not coming out of their houses.
今天大多数人都待在室内。他们哪儿也不去。他们不出家门。
April 25th, 88 days to Abdi's interview, and counting. It's a Friday, which normally would be a busy day in Eastleigh because it's a Muslim holy day. People take off from work, go shopping, go out to eat, and meet at the mosque for prayers. But not today. Abdi says last week, the police showed up at a nearby mosque, grabbed people as they left prayers, and drove them away in trucks.
4 月 25 日，距离面试还有 88 天，还在倒计时。今天是周五，通常这是东利最繁忙的一天，因为这是穆斯林的圣日。人们休息、购物、外出就餐，在清真寺聚会祈祷。但今天不是。阿卜迪说，上周，警察出现在附近的一座清真寺，在人们做完祈祷离开时将他们抓走，关进卡车带走了。
We're getting additional threats from the police, saying that they will intensify the operationism, that they will take more people.
我们收到警察额外的威胁，说他们将加强行动，抓捕更多的人。
So Abdi, what do you think you're going to do today? Will you visit a mosque?
那么阿卜迪，你觉得今天打算怎么做？会去清真寺吗？
No, I will not. I never missed a prayer on Friday, but this one. But this one. Never missed, but you never know.
不，我不会去。我从未错过周五的祈祷，除了这次。真的，从未错过，但你永远不知道会发生什么。
Soon, Abdi stops leaving his apartment for anything. He and his brother, Hassan, essentially go into hiding, locked down in their building. They stopped going to school.
很快，阿卜迪不再离开公寓做任何事。他和哥哥哈桑基本上躲了起来，锁在楼里。他们不再上学。
As the days go by, food begins to run short. Abdi and Hassan pool their supplies with another Somali family on the ground floor of their building-- two women, one a single mother with two small boys. But it's not much. Soon, they're down to just tea and sugar and a loaf of bread they're able to get each day from a Kenyan guy who delivers it on his bike. That's what they were living on-- tea and bread.
随着日子一天天过去，食物开始短缺。阿卜迪和哈桑与住在一楼的另一个索马里家庭分享物资——两个女人，其中一个是带着两个小男孩的单亲妈妈。但这也没多少东西。很快，他们只剩下茶和糖，以及每天从一个骑自行车派送的肯尼亚人那里买来的一条面包。这就是他们赖以生存的东西——茶和面包。
Our eyes are turning red, and the energy is running out. We're looking, like, pretty skinny.
我们的眼睛充血了，精力也耗尽了。我们看起来非常瘦。
Abdi and Hassan are paying for the tea and bread with money they get from overseas. Years ago, Abdi did some reports for an American public radio show called The Story, and a listener reached out wanting to help. She sends them money, not too different from lots of Somali refugees who have family members abroad supporting them. But obviously, that kind of help only goes so far.
阿卜迪和哈桑买茶和面包的钱来自海外。多年前，阿卜迪曾为一家名为《故事》的美国公共广播节目做过一些报道，一位听众联系了他希望能提供帮助。她给他们寄钱，这和许多有海外亲人支持的索马里难民没什么两样。但显然，这种帮助杯水车薪。
It's challenging, because you can't even shut your eyes at night and sleep soundly.
这很有挑战性，因为你甚至不能在晚上闭上眼睛好好睡一觉。
This is Abdi's older brother, Hassan. He tells me they aren't sleeping. He and Abdi sound the same, by the way. Apparently, even their father can't tell them apart on the phone.
这是阿卜迪的哥哥哈桑。他告诉我他们根本没法睡觉。顺便说一下，他和阿卜迪听起来一模一样。显然，连他们的父亲在电话里都分不清他们。
Any minute, you expect them breaking into your house or grabbing you. It's like sleeping with your pants on. You know, you are always ready. You don't know what's happening, you know?
随时你都会期待他们破门而入或把你抓走。这就像穿着裤子睡觉。你知道，你总是保持警惕。你不知道会发生什么，明白吗？
Yeah, wow.
是的，哇。
Feeling at home, it's like, you relax. You watch movie. It's something like-- that never happens. If you hear another sound outside, or some other knocking, or a small kind of sound, what was it? What's happening? Are they coming? We are not criminals, just we are refugees. And I never thought being a refugee will make you sound like criminal.
感觉像在家里，意味着你很放松。你会看电影。那东西……永远不会发生。如果你听到外面有声音，或者敲门声，或者一点点声响，心想：那是什么？发生了什么？他们来了吗？我们不是罪犯，我们只是难民。我从未想过作为一个难民会让你听起来像个罪犯。
The kind of police abuses Abdi told me about are well documented by human rights groups and journalists-- arbitrary arrests, extortion, beatings, forcible deportation, family members separated. It's illegal under international law to send refugees back to a country where their lives could be in danger.
阿卜迪告诉我的那些警察虐待行为，人权组织和记者都有详细记录——肆意逮捕、勒索、殴打、强行驱逐、妻离子散。根据国际法，将难民遣返回生命可能受到威胁的国家是非法的。
The spokesman for Kenya's Ministry of Interior, which oversaw the police raids in Eastleigh, told me they were justified to make the city safe from Al-Shabaab. But he confirmed that the kind of police corruption Abdi told me about has been a problem for a long time in Kenya. That is a fact, he said. We're not denying that.
负责监督东利警察突袭行动的肯尼亚内政部发言人告诉我，他们这样做是为了保证城市安全，免受青年党侵害。但他承认阿卜迪提到的那种警察腐败问题在肯尼亚确实存在很长时间了。他说：这是一个事实。我们并不否认。
Abdi and Hassan tell me Eastleigh's come up with a warning system. The first person to spot the police from his window fires a group text to his friends to say, they're coming your way, so you've got time to hide. Then you pass the message on to your friends, and so on. You can tell a raid started, Hassan says, when you hear all the phones going off.
阿卜迪和哈桑告诉我，东利社区建立了一套预警系统。第一个从窗口发现警察的人会给朋友发群短信说：他们往你们那边去了，快躲起来。然后你把消息传给你的朋友，以此类推。哈桑说，当听到手机铃声此起彼伏时，你就知道突袭开始了。
With just three months left til his interview, Abdi still needs to get all the documents required by the US embassy, documents from the police, his school, his doctors. But he can't do any of that, because he can't even leave his building. The clock's ticking.
距离面试只有三个月了，阿卜迪还需要获取美国大使馆要求的所有文件，包括来自警察、学校和医生的证明。但他什么也做不了，因为他甚至不能离开大楼。时间在流逝。
This is a long dream. My hopes were high to get this thing. But now today, I'm in trouble, you know?
这是一个长久的梦想。我对此期望很高。但现在今天，我遇到麻烦了，你懂吗？
Right.
明白。
It's not the Americans who are putting my visa into trouble. It's the Kenyans, the Kenyan police. And I'm supposed to have my interview here in July. My heart broke, you know? My feelings are very, very bad. I'm feeling like, OK, you're not going to make it.
不是美国人让我的签证陷入困境。是肯尼亚人，肯尼亚警察。我本应在七月在当地面试。我的心都碎了，你知道吗？我的感觉非常、非常糟糕。我感觉像：好吧，你成功不了了。
April 28th, T minus 85 days to his interview. Instead of hiding from the police, people are now surrendering. From his window, Abdi sees entire families sitting on the sidewalk with their belongings.
4 月 28 日，距离面试还有 85 天。人们不再躲避警察，而是投降了。阿卜迪从窗口看到整个家庭坐在人行道上，带着他们的行李。
Hundreds of families are on the move back to Somalia. They're ready to show themselves to the police and say, all right, I'm done.
数百个家庭正动身返回索马里。他们准备向警察自首说：好吧，我完了。
I'm done. They don't have any more money to pay off the police. And rather than end up at the football stadium, they'll just go back to Somalia. Even the family on the ground floor, the two women with the young boys, are packing up.
我完了。他们没有更多的钱贿赂警察。与其最终被关进足球场，他们宁愿直接回到索马里。连住在一楼的那家带两个小男孩的女人也正在打包行李。
Which really broke the heart of my brother and I, because that means we're going to be alone here.
这真的让我和哥哥心碎，因为这意味着我们要在这里孤身一人了。
Did you have any conversations with them about their plans, what they're afraid of? Can you tell me about any conversation you had with any member of that family?
你和他们谈过他们的计划吗，谈过他们害怕什么？你能跟我说说你和那家人的谈话吗？
What they are telling me, Abdi, what are you doing here? Come on, move. You're dream about America, that doesn't exist. This is a dream. Come on, boy. You're wrong. That's what they're telling me, Leo. At some point, I'm thinking, like, would be OK to go with them. This is totally no life.
他们对我说：阿卜迪，你在这里做什么？走吧，动身吧。你对美国的梦想根本不存在。这是一个梦想。走吧，孩子。你错了。这就是他们对我说的，里奥。在某个时刻，我甚至想：跟他们一起走或许也好。这根本不是生活。
I guess it can't be safe for two unaccompanied women with small children to be traveling by car from Nairobi to Somalia. It can't be safe, right?
我想两个无人陪伴带着小孩的女人开车从内罗毕前往索马里，不可能安全吧。这不可能安全，对吧？
They're expecting everything. They're expecting an extortion of property. They're expecting a rape, because there are gangs on the road that can rape women. And the gangs know that there are Somalis on the move, so they're somewhere on the road where there's no police inside. So they can come and jump into buses, rape women, take their money.
他们预料到了一切。他们预料到会被勒索财产。他们预料到会被强奸，因为路上有团伙会伤害妇女。这些团伙知道有索马里人在迁徙，所以他们埋伏在没有警察的路上。他们可以跳上公共汽车，强奸妇女，抢走她们的钱。
And the other thing that these families are fearing when they reach at the border between Kenya and Somalia, another chapter of danger begins, because it's Al-Shabaab that are lurking around the border. And when you fall into the hands of Al-Shabaab, you disappear forever.
当这些家庭到达肯尼亚和索马里边境时，另一章危险就开始了，因为青年党就在边境附近徘徊。一旦落入青年党手中，你就永远消失了。
The other thing that I was also discussing with them about this seven-year-old and five-year-old kids, because these are the age that the Al-Shabaab really want to program the kids and teach them whatever ideologies they believe. And so yeah, the lady looked like she was so much worried for her kids than for herself. Knowing this, these two ladies and the kids must go.
我还和他们讨论了关于七岁和五岁孩子的问题，因为这些年龄的孩子正是青年党想要洗脑、灌输他们信仰的意识形态的目标。所以是的，那位女士看起来比担心自己更担心孩子。考虑到这些，这两位女士和孩子必须离开。
Wow.
天哪。
It's really. So you've got a lot of things to think about, a lot of things to worry about.
真的是这样。所以你有太多的事情要考虑，太多的担忧。
One night on the phone, Abdi asked me if I'm familiar with the migration of the wildebeest. Abdi wants to be clear he doesn't know about this, because he's African. He's a city kid. He's just seen it on Discovery Channel clips like everyone else.
一天晚上在电话里，阿卜迪问我是否了解角马迁徙。阿卜迪想声明他了解这个，因为他是非洲人。他是城市长大的孩子，他只是像其他人一样在探索频道的片段里见过。
Anyway, each year thousands and thousands of wildebeest trek to a river that they have to cross in order to graze on the other side. The river's infested with crocodiles, and not every wildebeest makes it. But they all have to try. Abdi says he knows how they feel. Somalis are prey, he says. They're being hunted.
总之，每年有成千上万的角马长途跋涉到一条河边，为了在对岸吃草它们必须渡河。河里满是鳄鱼，并非每头角马都能活下来。但它们都必须尝试。阿卜迪说他明白那种感觉。他说索马里人是猎物。他们正在被捕猎。
Each evening when I phoned Abdi, I was always concerned that one night, no one would answer, that he would have finally taken the advice of his neighbors, or been hauled off to the holding pens in Kasarani. But when he did pick up, often he wanted to talk about things that weren't related to the Kenyan police or Al-Shabaab. We talked about his favorite movies, Rambo, that movie, The Rock with Nicolas Cage, anything Schwarzenegger. We talked about his friends in the good old days in Eastleigh when you could sit in a cafe and sip tea with camel milk.
每天晚上给阿卜迪打电话时，我总是担心某天晚上没人接听，担心他终于听从了邻居的建议，或者被拖到了卡萨拉尼的拘留所。但当他接听时，他通常想谈论些与肯尼亚警察或青年党无关的事。我们谈论他最喜欢的电影：《第一滴血》、尼古拉斯·凯奇的《勇闯夺命岛》、施瓦辛格的一切。我们谈论他在东利美好时光里的朋友，那时可以在咖啡馆喝杯骆驼奶茶。
One thing I asked Abdi about, when people win the regular lottery, you always hear stories about how, all of a sudden, family members are really nice to them, how cousins they haven't spoken to in years start calling to say hi, asking for favors. I wondered if this was the case with Abdi. Here he was sitting in a slum with all these refugees who were in the same terrible situation, and now he had a ticket out. Did people start treating him differently?
我问过阿卜迪一件事，当人们赢得常规抽签时，你总会听到一些故事，说那些亲戚突然对他们非常好，多年没说话的表亲开始打电话来问候、请求帮忙。我想知道阿卜迪是否也遇到了这种情况。他当时坐在贫民窟里，和所有同样处境凄惨的难民在一起，现在他却有了去美国的门票。人们开始对他另眼相看吗？
Yes, Leo, especially the girls. This is a very good question.
是的，里奥，尤其是女孩子们。这真是个好问题。
Abdi's a practicing Muslim, and so are the women he hangs out with. So normally before, you could only visit them in a kind of formal courtship visit at their home-- no having girls over to his place, no hanging out in public.
阿卜迪是虔诚的穆斯林，他来往的女孩子也是。所以通常以前，你只能在他们家进行某种正式的求爱访问——不能让女孩子去他家，不能在公共场合闲逛。
The difference now, since I won the green card lottery, is that they are trying to come to my house.
现在的区别在于，自从我赢得绿卡抽签后，她们开始试图来我家。
He's talking about before the police raids started, when life was relatively normal in Eastleigh.
他说的是警察突袭开始之前，东利生活还相对正常的时候。
So I just hear someone coming up the stairs and knocking at my door and saying, hey, Abdi, how have you been? And it's a lady. And yeah, she sits right next to your bed, and it's all about the conversation. She's trying to do anything to attract you with the sweet words.
所以我只是听到有人走上楼梯敲我的门说：嘿，阿卜迪，你怎么样？是个女士。是的，她就坐在你的床边，整晚都在聊天。她试图用甜言蜜语做任何事来吸引你。
Hi. Do you have a girlfriend? When do you want to marry? What type of girls do you want? Now you're going to America, you need a wife. When you go to America, please let me be the first person that you [INAUDIBLE], because I'm here, and I don't have a husband.
你好。你有女朋友吗？你想什么时候结婚？你喜欢什么样的女孩？现在你要去美国了，你需要一个妻子。当你去美国时，请让我成为你[听不清]的第一个人，因为我在这儿，我没有丈夫。
Are you thinking about any of these girls? Maybe something could happen.
你有考虑过其中任何一个女孩吗？也许可能会发生点什么。
Yes. I really am attracted to one of these girls. She's really beautiful, cute. She's Somali, but she has finished high school in Nairobi. The good thing about her is that she speaks English. She is really, I think, my type. She likes to read a lot, you know?
是的。我确实被其中一个女孩吸引了。她真的很漂亮，可爱。她是索马里人，但在内罗毕读完了高中。她好的一点是她会说英语。我想她确实是我的类型。她喜欢阅读，你知道吗？
She has a different character. The rest of Somali girls are very shy, but this pretty girl she gives me all this confidence. And she allows me to go to her, and she allows me to hang out with her in downtown Nairobi, wherever possible. So yeah, I think I fall in love.
她的性格与众不同。剩下的索马里女孩都很害羞，但这个漂亮的女孩给了我所有的自信。她允许我去找她，允许我和她在内罗毕市中心逛，只要有可能。所以是的，我想我坠入爱河了。
Well, congratulations. That's one piece of good news.
好吧，恭喜你。这是个好消息。
Yeah. But unfortunately for the last four weeks, we haven't seen each other. [LAUGHS]
是的。但不幸的是，过去四个星期我们没见过面。[笑]
May 1st, 82 days and counting. Abdi cautiously ventures out of the apartment building for the first time in weeks. He heads downtown to central Nairobi where life is continuing as normal. It's a stressful journey, but he's able to buy a couple of gallons of clean water and some cans of beans to bring home. He says it's amazing how good these taste to him and Hassan. He tells me he's getting more and more worried about the paperwork he still has to get together for his interview-- his medical records and transcripts from his university. And there's one piece of paper that terrifies him.
5 月 1 日，距离还有 82 天。阿卜迪数周来第一次小心翼翼地走出公寓大楼。他前往内罗毕市中心，那里生活一如既往。这趟旅程压力很大，但他成功买了几加仑干净水和几罐豆子带回家。他说这对于他和哈桑来说味道好极了。他告诉我，他越来越担心面试所需的文件——医疗记录和大学成绩单。有一份文件让他感到恐惧。
One of the US embassy requirements is to get a police certificate, something called a Certificate of Good Conduct.
美国大使馆的要求之一是获得警察证明，即所谓的“品行良好证明”。
What this basically is is proof from Kenyan law enforcement that Abdi isn't a criminal. Abdi doesn't have a record, so this shouldn't be a big deal, except for the place he has to go to get the official certificate-- the headquarters of the Kenyan police.
这基本上是肯尼亚执法部门证明阿卜迪不是罪犯。阿卜迪没有犯罪记录，所以这本不该是大问题，但获得官方证明的地方——肯尼亚警察总部——让他心惊胆战。
So that scares you a lot. Thousands of Somalis are being held, as we speak. And they are waiting for their return to Somalia, or some of them are waiting for their return to the camps. So while I'm thinking of jumping into a bus and headed to headquarters, stepping in there and saying, hey, guys, I need a police letter, my heart is already pounding.
所以这让你很害怕。正如我们谈话时，成千上万的索马里人被关押着。他们等着被遣返回索马里，或者等着回到难民营。所以当我想到要坐上一辆公交车去总部，走进那儿说：嘿，伙计们，我需要一份警察证明，我的心已经在砰砰直跳了。
For weeks, Abdi had been talking to me about this, telling me how worried he was about having to go into the belly of the beast. Finally, on a Tuesday morning in May, 77 days before his interview, he gets up early, gets together every ID he has to prove he's a legal refugee, says goodbye to Hassan, and takes a bus to police headquarters. He walks in, waits for his name to be called, and walks up to the window where he faces a Kenyan police officer. And what he encounters is not brutal police tactics, but bureaucracy.
几周来，阿卜迪一直在跟我谈论这个，告诉我他有多担心必须走进虎穴。终于，在五月的一个周二早上，面试前 77 天，他一大早就起床，带上证明他是合法难民的所有身份证件，跟哈桑道别，坐公交去警察总部。他走进去，等名字被叫到，然后走到窗口面对肯尼亚警察。他遇到的不是粗暴的警察手段，而是官僚主义。
He was telling me, there's nothing that I can do but take your paperwork and send it to UNSCR. And then I have to wait for that to come back to me. Even it can take more than five months, he tells me.
他告诉我：我什么也做不了，只能收下你的文件寄给联合国难民署（UNHCR）。然后我必须等它寄回来。他说，甚至可能需要五个多月。
Five months-- way too long for Abdi to have it in time for his interview on July 22nd.
五个月——对于阿卜迪来说太长了，赶不上 7 月 22 日的面试。
The guy there was not friendly. He was really, really fierce. And I was frozen with fear. And finally I tell him, wait, just listen to me, gentleman. You're talking about five months, sir, but that's not what I'm talking about. If I don't get this police certificate, they will not give me or issue a visa for me, all right? So please, is it possible? And he was telling me, there's nothing that I can do for you. It's going to take more than five months.
窗口那个人不友好。他非常非常凶。我吓呆了。最后我告诉他：等等，先生，请听我说。你在谈论五个月，先生，但那不是我想要的。如果我拿不到这份警察证明，他们就不会给我颁发签证，对吧？所以拜托，有可能吗？他回答我：我帮不了你。这需要五个多月。
There's no possibility of you going into a later position with the US Embassy, is there?
你不可能向美国大使馆申请延期面试时间，对吗？
No.
不能。
No?
不能？
It doesn't happen. If you delay your interview, that's the end of it. Some other people will grab the visa. Yeah. Then it's going to be a doom.
那是不可能的。如果你推迟面试，就彻底没戏了。其他人会抢走这个名额。是的。那将是灭顶之灾。
It's going to be a doom, Abdi says. And I felt that, too. Up to this point, it seemed like if Abdi could just hold on long enough to get to his embassy interview, he'd make it to America. Now, all bets were off. Now, unless this changed, there was no way.
阿卜迪说这将是灭顶之灾。我也感同身受。直到现在，似乎只要阿卜迪能坚持到大使馆面试，他就能去美国。现在，一切都悬了。除非情况改变，否则根本不可能。
Leo Hornak. Abdi decides to keep going back to police headquarters every few weeks, despite the risk, despite how frightening it is, to see if one time maybe he gets a different answer. What happens next in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
里奥·霍纳克。阿卜迪决定尽管有风险，尽管这非常可怕，还是每隔几周就去一次警察总部，看看会不会有不同的答案。接下来会发生什么，芝加哥公共广播电台将在节目继续后一分钟揭晓。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, we're replaying the story of Abdi Nor, just three weeks after the ceremony where he finally became a US citizen. Abdi's a Somali refugee, who escaped to Kenya. And then he won what amounts to a golden ticket to move to the United States and become an American, but only if he's able to make it to an interview at the US embassy, with all the right paperwork, all done perfectly, so he can cash in that golden ticket.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目重播阿卜迪·诺尔的故事，就在他最终成为美国公民的仪式三周后。阿卜迪是一名索马里难民，他逃到了肯尼亚。然后他赢得了移居美国并成为美国人的“金奖券”，但前提是他必须带着所有完美的文书工作，去美国大使馆参加面试，才能兑现那张金奖券。
The United Nations has reported that the number of people around the world displaced from their homes because of conflict and persecution is at an all time high. It's over 70 million people, the largest number the UN has ever recorded. Abdi, of course, is one of those people. He's Muslim, from a country with a proven history of terrorism.
联合国报告称，全世界因冲突和迫害而背井离乡的人数处于历史最高水平。超过 7000 万人，是联合国记录过的最高数字。阿卜迪当然也是其中之一。他是穆斯林，来自一个有恐怖主义历史证明的国家。
The story all happened back in 2013, but today, under President Trump's travel ban, a Somali like Abdi would not be allowed a visa to immigrate into the United States. Anyway, Leo Hornak continues our story.
这一切发生在 2013 年，但今天，在特朗普总统的旅行禁令下，像阿卜迪这样的索马里人将不被允许获得移民美国的签证。无论如何，里奥·霍纳克继续我们的故事。
May 12th, T minus 71 days to Abdi's embassy interview. Abdi gets on a bus home from school and, this time, runs into another danger-- not the police, not Al-Shabaab themselves, but the fear of Al-Shabaab.
5 月 12 日，距离阿卜迪大使馆面试还有 71 天。阿卜迪放学回家坐公交车，这一次，他遇到了另一种危险——不是警察，也不是青年党本身，而是人们对青年党的恐惧。
The bus is so crowded with people. And there are these two ladies watching me.
公交车上挤满了人。有两个女士盯着我看。
Abdi looks around and realizes he's the only Somali. People can tell. Somalis look different. And a Somali with a backpack on, on a public bus? He knows what people are thinking.
阿卜迪环顾四周，发现他是唯一的索马里人。人们看得出来。索马里人长相不同。一个背着背包的索马里人在公交车上？他知道人们在想什么。
They're watching my hands. They're thinking, like, when is this guy putting his hand into that bag and start to blow up? This lady then started shouting at the driver, have you made sure there's no bomb in that bag?
她们盯着我的手。她们心想：这人什么时候会把手伸进包里然后引爆炸弹？这位女士开始对着司机大喊：你确定包里没有炸弹吗？
I had to fight back. And I say, listen, lady, wait a minute. I'm not what you think I am, you know? No, there's no bomb here. I'm not one of those people. I'm a student, and I'm carrying my books. It's quite embarrassing. And at the same time I feel fear, because everyone in there had very cautious eyes on me.
我不得不反击。我说：听着，女士，等一下。我不是你想的那样，你知道吗？没有，这儿没有炸弹。我不是那些人。我是个学生，我背着书。这太尴尬了。同时我也感到恐惧，因为车里每个人的眼神都充满警惕。
In Kenya, because people don't trust the police, mobs will take justice into their own hands. For example, if a shopkeeper yells "thief" on the street, strangers might grab the person and beat them. And it's not unheard of for people to die this way. A man in the back of the bus chimes in. Why is he there? He shouts, kick him out.
在肯尼亚，因为人们不信任警察，暴徒会私下里动用私刑。例如，如果店主在街上大喊“小偷”，陌生人可能会抓住那个人并殴打他。这样导致死亡的情况也并非闻所未闻。车后座的一个男人插话了。他为什么要在这里？他大喊：把他踢出去！
I tried as much as I can to calm them down. And they were ignoring me. And then the driver turns his head and tells me, boy, step out of my car. All right, call the police.
我尽我所能试图让他们冷静下来。但他们不理我。然后司机转过头对我说：小伙子，下车。去，去报警。
And you know, we weren't in Little Mogadishu. We weren't in downtown. We were in the middle. And in the middle, what I mean in the middle, is exactly the Bengali police station.
你知道，我们当时不在小摩加迪沙，也不在市中心。我们在中间。我的意思是，刚好就在孟加拉警察局旁边。
This is the police station Somali terrorists bombed two weeks earlier.
这就是两周前被索马里恐怖分子炸毁的警察局。
What do you think? If they kick me out there with a bag standing there near the police station, what's going to happen? They can shoot me to death.
你觉得呢？如果他们把我踢下车，带着包站在警察局附近，会发生什么？他们可以开枪把我打死。
I said to the driver, wait a minute. You want to know what's in here? And then I had to unzip my bag and bring everything out-- the books, the papers. Showed him the pen, the ID, student ID. Everything, I brought out.
我对司机说：等等，先生。你想知道里面有什么吗？于是我不得不拉开包的拉链，把所有东西都掏出来——书、纸。给他看笔、身份证、学生证。所有东西，我都拿出来了。
And then I hang the bag upside down and showed him. Do you see anything in there? And then it looked like the driver was kind of satisfied. He looked straight, and he drove the car a little bit faster.
然后我把包倒过来展示给他看。你看到里面有东西吗？司机看起来好像满意了。他看着前方，把车开得快了些。
Four days later, May 16th, 67 days to the interview, Al-Shabaab blows up two buses. It's a big deal. They were in a Central Market-- at least 12 dead, more than 70 injured. Abdi is sure the police will be out in force, and he hunkers down at home for a while.
四天后，5 月 16 日，距离面试 67 天，青年党炸了两辆公交车。这是一件大事。袭击发生在中央市场——至少 12 人死亡，超过 70 人受伤。阿卜迪确信警察会大举出动，于是他躲在家里一段时间。
Hey, Abdi. What's up? How's it going?
嘿，阿卜迪。怎么了？近况如何？
Leo, it's good. How are you?
里奥，挺好的。你好吗？
Yeah, not too bad at all. Could you tell me the date? And then we can start.
不错。你能告诉我日期吗？然后我们开始。
The date?
日期？
Yeah.
对。
It's May 17, 2014. And last night after that explosion, there was a massive operation in Little Mogadishu. They've knocked at our house. It was like 2:00 last night. We haven't opened. They just kept knocking. And they were thinking, like, there's nobody here. And then they have moved.
2014 年 5 月 17 日。昨晚爆炸发生后，小摩加迪沙发生了大规模行动。他们敲了我们的门。大概凌晨 2 点。我们没开。他们一直敲。他们心想这里没人。然后他们就走开了。
So hang on. So they kind of-- if they just don't get any answer, then they think it's empty?
等一下。如果没人应门，他们就认为这屋是空的？
Yes. The thing is that Eastleigh is not like before. Now, there are no more people at all. 80% have gone. That's what I think. It was like 50% before. Now, it's 80%.
是的。关键是东利已经和以前不同了。现在，这里已经几乎没人了。80% 的人都走了。我是这么想的。之前大概是 50%。现在是 80%。
Most buildings are empty. So these days when they keep knocking and nobody's opening, they're thinking, like, people here have moved. So yes, that's what we did last night. We just-- none of us opened.
大多数楼房都空了。所以这些天当他们一直敲门没人开时，他们心想：这里的人搬走了。所以是的，我们昨晚就是这么做的。我们谁也没开门。
There was no light in our house. Because these guys, they're listening to the movements. They're watching if there's any movement in the windows. They are seeing if there's a light, or something. Just something like that shows them there's a life here. So that's what we do. We don't show there's a life. It's totally blackout.
我们家没开灯。因为这些家伙，他们在听动静。他们在观察窗户是否有动静。他们在看是否有灯光，或者类似的东西。仅仅是那样，就能告诉他们这里还有活人。所以这就是我们要做的。我们不显示这里有活人。完全停电。
Good evening, Leo.
晚安，里奥。
Hey, Abdi. How are you?
嘿，阿卜迪。你好吗？
I'm good. I'm good, Leo. How are you?
很好，里奥。你好吗？
Good. I'm pleased to hear it. I know that you had a tough, a very difficult evening. Do you want to say what the date is and tell me what happened?
很好。很高兴听到你这么说。我知道你度过了一个艰难、非常困难的夜晚。你想说一下日期并告诉我发生了什么吗？
May 19. Now the time is 8:45. All I can say, Leo, is that I haven't slept for the last, I can say, 30 hours or more, because the police raid has increased. They have come and taken so many people from our neighborhood. And we have realized that this is not the ordinary police. They have changed something.
5 月 19 日。现在是 8:45。我只能说，里奥，过去 30 小时甚至更久我都没合眼，因为警察的突袭加剧了。他们闯入并从我们的街区带走了很多人。我们意识到这不是普通的警察。他们改变了策略。
These guys, they don't negotiate on cash. Everything has changed. They're not going into any negotiation at all. They throw you in the back of their trucks and drive away. So many, so many refugees for the last--
这些家伙，他们不协商现金。一切都变了。他们根本不进入任何协商。他们把你扔进卡车后厢就开走了。过去这段时间有太多、太多的难民——
And how are you finding this out? How do you know this?
你是怎么发现这些的？你是怎么知道的？
Well, I told you already about that girl. She's my-- I can say she's my girlfriend now, but she has a Kenyan national ID. The text message she sent me here, it says, hey, they have been with me for, like, 15 minutes, where she was just sleeping, her room.
好吧，我已经跟你说过那个女孩了。她是我的——可以说现在是我的女朋友，但她有肯尼亚国民身份证。她发给我的短信上写着：嘿，他们在我这儿呆了 15 分钟，当时我正在房间睡觉。
And one of them said, you are not supposed to be a Somali. You're a Kenyan, so you can be my wife. That's one of the policeman, what one of the policeman said when she showed them her Kenyan national ID. I'm taking all the Somalis, so you would be lonely here. Just come, and you will be safe. You will live with me. And she said, please leave me alone.
其中一个人说：你不应该是索马里人。你是肯尼亚人，你可以做我的妻子。当她给他们看肯尼亚身份证时，其中一名警察这样说。我正在抓所有的索马里人，所以你会孤身一人的。跟我走，你会很安全。你会和我生活在一起。她说：请让我一个人呆着。
They took everyone else in the compound where she lived who had a refugee ID. She lived with other girls. And the other girls don't have the national ID, so they forced the girls out. They have finally forced the girls out.
他们带走了她住处里的所有人，那些有难民身份证的人。她和其他女孩住在一起。其他女孩没有国民身份证，所以他们强行把女孩们带走了。他们最终强行把女孩们带走了。
I tried to confirm this with his girlfriend, but she didn't want to talk to me about it. Abdi says the police took her roommates that night, but left her behind.
我试图和他的女朋友确认这件事，但她不想跟我谈。阿卜迪说警察那天晚上带走了她的室友，但留下了她。
So what? She's alone now? What's the situation?
那怎么说？她现在是一个人了？情况如何？
She is alone, yes. So Leo, yes, that last night, Hassan and I, we didn't know where to go. We could hear all those sounds-- the knob of our gate, the shouts, the bullets that were being fired into the doors of people. At one moment I was thinking, like, go under your bed. And then a moment, I was thinking like, if they find you here, they're going to kill you. I was like, this is-- I don't know. I've never been in such a stressful situation.
是的，她一个人。所以里奥，昨晚我和哈桑不知道该往哪儿走。我们能听到所有的声音——大门锁动的声音、喊叫声、射入人们门里的子弹声。那一刻我心想：躲到床下去。下一刻我又想：如果他们在这儿找到你，他们会杀了你的。我当时就像……我不知道。我从未处于压力这么大的境地。
So if you were to look outside the building right now, what would you see?
那么如果你现在往楼外看，你会看到什么？
Leo, to be honest-- Leo--
里奥，老实说——里奥——
I'm not asking you to. I know it's dangerous, but just help me imagine.
我不强求你这样做。我知道这很危险，但帮我想象一下。
Leo, to be honest, if I just look through my window, there's nothing that I can see, I'm telling you, there's nothing that I can see. All the lights are off. Even there's no street light here now.
里奥，老实说，如果我透过窗户往外看，什么也看不到，我告诉你，确实什么也看不到。所有的灯都关了。现在连路灯都没有了。
It's totally, totally dark. There's only this light coming from the laptop. We have to put lots of things on the windows so that they cannot even see-- that's what I'm doing right now-- so that they cannot even see the light from my laptop.
一片漆黑，完全黑暗。只有笔记本电脑发出的光。我们必须在窗户上放很多东西，这样他们甚至看不到——这就是我现在正在做的——这样他们甚至看不到我笔记本发出的光。
But Leo, I don't know. I don't know why they come midnight. Why is that? Because they don't want us to go to sleep? Why don't they come during the day? They usually come the same time, 2:30, 2:30, you know? And that's exactly when Somali women and children are all asleep and that these guys are coming.
但是里奥，我不知道。我不知道为什么他们要在半夜来。为什么？因为他们不想让我们睡觉吗？为什么他们不在白天来？他们通常在同一时间来，2:30，2:30，你知道吗？这正是索马里妇女和儿童都在睡觉的时候，这些家伙就来了。
They kick the door open, telling you, wake up, terrorist. Wake up. Why are you sleeping? They're coming back every night. What the hell is going on? Why don't they-- at least if they're doing an operation, why don't they come at one time and finish the hell the whole thing? They're killing us. They're killing us by fearing.
他们把门踹开，对你大喊：醒醒，恐怖分子。醒醒。为什么在睡觉？他们每晚都回来。这到底是怎么回事？为什么他们——如果是在执行任务，为什么不一次性把这该死的事全办完？他们在杀死我们。他们用恐惧杀死我们。
In this situation, it must be easy for Al-Shabaab to get supporters, I guess-- people who have maybe a little bit of sympathy with their ideas.
在这种情况下，青年党应该很容易获得支持者吧——人们可能对他们的想法有一点同情心。
Did you read or did you hear about the young men who were deported from Kenya to Somalia have already joined Al-Shabaab?
你读到或者听说过那些从肯尼亚被驱逐回索马里的年轻人已经加入青年党了吗？
No, I didn't see that.
没有，我没看到。
They are coming from the border already, attacking Kenya as revenge, because the Kenyans have really mistreated so many women, and children, and so many young men. Kenya is really giving a very good opportunity to these Al-Shabaab guys, because they are getting what they wanted. They are getting the young men that they were looking for.
他们已经在边境集结了，开始攻击肯尼亚作为报复，因为肯尼亚人真的虐待了太多的妇女、儿童和年轻人。肯尼亚确实给了这些青年党家伙一个很好的机会，因为他们得到了他们想要的。他们得到了他们一直在寻找的年轻人。
Yeah. Well, I wish I could say more, but I think there's nothing more I can say right now.
是啊。好吧，我希望我能多说点，但我认为现在没有什么可以多说的了。
I know all I need is some sleep. I don't know if you can feel that, but my eyes now--
我知道我需要的是睡眠。我不知道你能不能感觉到，但我的眼睛现在——
I can. I can. I can hear you feel very stressed. I hope you get some sleep and keep safe as well, as safe as you can with your good luck, I mean.
我可以，我可以。我能听出你压力非常大。希望你能睡一觉，并且保持安全，在你的好运气下尽可能安全，我的意思是。
Thanks, Leo. Good luck to you, too.
谢谢，里奥。祝你好运。
Days go by. Abdi and Hassan do their best to keep their spirits up and entertain themselves. They read books. They watch Lost and Walking Dead. It's one of the weird quirks of Eastleigh that, even if food runs short, you can still have good broadband internet. They even build makeshift barbells out of old milk cans they've filled with sand and stones and start working out.
日子一天天过去。阿卜迪和哈桑尽力保持精神状态并娱乐自己。他们读书。他们看《迷失》和《行尸走肉》。东利有一个奇怪的特点，即使食物短缺，你仍然可以使用优质的宽带互联网。他们甚至用装满沙子和石头的旧牛奶罐制作了简易哑铃，开始锻炼。
1, 2, 3.
1，2，3。
And they do one of Abdi's favorite things.
他们做阿卜迪最喜欢的事情之一。
You want me to go out and get--
你想让我出去拿——
Yes.
是的。
OK.
好的。
Listen to music.
听音乐。
[MUSIC - "CARELESS WHISPER" BY GEORGE MICHAEL]
[音乐 - 乔治·迈克尔的《Careless Whisper》]
Back in Somalia, if Al-Shabaab caught you with MP3s on your phone, they would flog you. Or they could even kill you for it. They believe most music is sinful. But Abdi always took a risk. He kept his music collection on a secret SIM card hidden under the mattress.
回到索马里，如果青年党抓到你手机里有 MP3，他们会鞭打你。或者甚至可能因此杀了你。他们认为大多数音乐都是罪恶的。但阿卜迪总是冒着风险。他把音乐收藏在一个藏在床垫下的秘密 SIM 卡里。
This song, called "Careless Whisper," give me some good memories. Because in Somalia, we really had very few Western songs. And there was one time that they got this song and made it into Somali. They translated it.
这首歌叫《Careless Whisper》，带给我很多美好的回忆。因为在索马里，我们真的很少有西方歌曲。有一次他们拿到了这首歌并把它翻唱成索马里语。他们翻译了它。
Wow.
哇。
Yeah, yeah. I would love to play you that. I don't know if it-- let me think where we can get it. Yeah.
是的，是的。我很想放给你听。我不知道它——让我想想我们在哪里能找到它。是的。
[MUSIC - "CARELESS WHISPER" BY MUKTAR IDI RAMADAN]
[音乐 - 穆克塔尔·伊迪·拉马丹的《Careless Whisper》]
To be very honest, I have so many songs on my phone, but most of them are very, very old. I really enjoy them. Because I remember my father and the beautiful days in Somalia, he used to play these songs. Because he had this big radio. I'm talking about the '90s, when I was a pretty young guy.
老实说，我手机里有很多歌，但大多数都非常、非常古老。我真的很享受它们。因为我想起我父亲和在索马里的美好日子，他过去常放这些歌。因为他有这个大收音机。我指的是 90 年代，当我还是个小孩的时候。
And my father used to sit like this. He's leaning against the wall. His big radio was right next to him. And next to him is a flask full of hot tea with his khat. And the khat is the small leaves that Somalis eat as a stimulant. And next to him is also a bowl full of milk.
我父亲过去常像这样坐着。他靠在墙上。他的大收音机就在他身边。他旁边放着装满热茶和卡特草的烧瓶。卡特草是索马里人作为兴奋剂咀嚼的小叶子。他旁边还有一个装满牛奶的碗。
Oh, my god. My father, when he has all that stuff, he's in heaven. He's smiling. He gets his finger on the tape, and he makes us quiet. He says, shut up, and just enjoy.
哦，天哪。我父亲，当他有这些东西时，就像在天堂。他微笑着。他把手指按在磁带上，让我们安静。他说：闭嘴，好好享受。
During all this, Abdi did leave the house sometimes, but only for a very specific reason-- either to go to an important class he couldn't miss, or to go to the police headquarters and try his luck again getting the certificate he needs for his interview. Then on May 29th, with 54 days and counting, Abdi sends me this recording.
在此期间，阿卜迪有时会离开家，但仅限于非常特定的原因——要么去一门不能缺席的重要课程，要么去警察总部碰碰运气，看能否拿到面试所需的证明。然后，在 5 月 29 日，距离面试还有 54 天，阿卜迪发给我这段录音。
Hi, this is Abdi. I have great news to declare, so let me just-- I'm so excited. Oh, my god. I'm really different today. My police clearance is done. Let me say that again. My police clearance is done.
你好，我是阿卜迪。我有好消息要宣布，所以让我——我太兴奋了。哦，天哪。我今天真是完全不同了。我的警察证明搞定了。让我再说一遍。我的警察证明搞定了。
I'm looking at my hand, fingers. They're all black, because I'm still wearing the black ink for the fingerprints. And I'm not sorry about it. I smell the US visa. I smell it. I smell it. I see July 22 coming. This was the only problem. I dealt with it. It's done.
我看着我的手，手指。它们都是黑色的，因为我手指上还沾着指纹黑墨水。我不觉得这有什么。我闻到了美国签证的味道。我闻到了。我闻到了。我看到了 7 月 22 日正在到来。这是唯一的问题。我搞定了。完成了。
At this point, Abdi's a shoo-in. It's almost hard to believe after all the obstacles. But he calls up the embassy, talks through all the paperwork, and they tell him he's good to go. And they'll see him on the 22nd. And his tune on our nightly phone calls totally changes, from this--
此时，阿卜迪已经胜券在握。经历了所有障碍后，这几乎令人难以置信。但他给大使馆打电话，沟通了所有文书工作，他们告诉他一切就绪。他们会在 22 日见他。他每天晚上的电话语气完全变了，从这个——
My heart broke, you know? I'm feeling like, OK, you're not going to make it.
我的心都碎了，你知道吗？我感觉：好吧，你成功不了了。
--to this.
——到这个。
Now I'm in love with the American culture. I'm in love with their beautiful roads and streets, houses. I'm in love with everything, everything in the United States that's going on.
现在我爱上了美国文化。我爱上了他们美丽的道路、街道、房子。我爱上了一切，美国正在发生的一切。
Do you sometimes worry that maybe you're so in love with this place that it might disappoint you when you reach there? Many people who reach America have a very tough time.
你有时会担心吗？也许你太爱这个地方了，以至于当你到达那里时，它可能会让你失望？许多到达美国的人处境非常艰难。
Mm-hmm. No, I don't worry about that, because I know whatever I have been through, they've never been through. I've been a refugee. I've been hiding from police. I've been hiding from Shabaab. I've been hiding from so many armed groups. I have had enough trouble. I have had enough disappointment. America is an opportunity, so I'll take my chances.
嗯。不，我不担心这个，因为我知道我经历过的任何事，他们从未经历过。我当过难民。我躲避过警察。我躲避过青年党。我躲避过那么多武装团体。我受够了麻烦。我受够了失望。美国是一个机会，所以我愿意冒这个险。
And America is an opportunity not just for Abdi, but his whole family.
而美国不仅是阿卜迪的机会，也是他全家的机会。
My mother is in Somalia. She's in Mogadishu, the most dangerous city in the world. And so every call that's coming from Mogadishu, I pick up really with shaky hands.
我母亲在索马里。她在摩加迪沙，世界上最危险的城市。所以每一个从摩加迪沙打来的电话，我都带着颤抖的手接起。
Abdi hasn't seen his mother in more than three years. She lives in a tiny, rundown shack made of corrugated tin. And she doesn't always have access to enough food or clean water. If Abdi gets to America, he hopes he can make some money. And even if he can't protect her from violence, he can at least help her to get a better place with clean water and three meals a day.
阿卜迪已经三年多没见母亲了。她住在一个用波纹铁皮做的破旧小屋里。而且她并不总能获得足够的食物或干净的饮用水。如果阿卜迪能去美国，他希望能挣些钱。即使他不能保护她免受暴力，他至少能帮她找个有干净水和一日三餐更好的住处。
I spoke to my mother yesterday evening. She asked, boy, when are you going out of that country? And I said, mom, I've got 52 days. 52 days. I need your prayers. And she said, oh, my god, he's got 52 days. I'm praying for you, boy.
我昨天晚上和母亲谈过了。她问：孩子，你什么时候离开那个国家？我说：妈，还有 52 天。52 天。我需要你的祈祷。她说：哦，天哪，还有 52 天。我在为你祈祷，孩子。
And I know, like I am right now, she's counting the days. It's going to be something that will make her proud, that will make her survive. She's really sending all her prayers towards me.
我知道，就像现在的我一样，她在倒计时。这将是一件让她自豪的事，让她生存下去的事。她真的在把所有的祈祷传向我。
Abdi's older brother, Hassan, has also applied for the visa lottery. Like Abdi, he's worked for years on his English. He came to Kenya years before Abdi. Now he's getting ready to live alone again.
阿卜迪的哥哥哈桑也申请了签证抽签。像阿卜迪一样，他多年来一直在学习英语。他比阿卜迪早几年来到肯尼亚。现在他正准备再次独自生活。
Hassan, is there a part of you that thinks, just a little part of you that is a bit jealous about Abdi? Because you both worked hard. And Abdi has got this not through hard work, but by luck.
哈桑，你内心有没有一部分，哪怕只有一小部分，对阿卜迪感到嫉妒？因为你们俩都很努力。而阿卜迪得到这个不是靠努力工作，而是靠运气。
Actually, if I tell you, I don't have the least jealousy at all. If we get two of us visa to get out here, it would even be better. But if someone told me right now, there is one visa, which one of you will take? I would say Abdi, because he's new to this country. And I know how we are so fearful at night. And I know how he can't sleep at night. For him to get visa is my biggest pleasure. Yeah, there's luck there, but luck can be fair.
说实话，我一点嫉妒都没有。如果我们两人都能拿到签证离开这里，那就更好了。但如果现在有人告诉我：这里有一张签证，你们谁要？我会说阿卜迪，因为他是新来的。我知道我们晚上是多么恐惧。我知道他晚上睡不着觉。他能拿到签证是我最大的快乐。是的，这有运气成分，但运气可以很公平。
June 4th, 48 days and counting. Abdi goes into the stairwell to use the bathroom and finds a police officer standing there, who calls for backup. The officer doesn't ask for a bribe. He lets Abdi go. Abdi has no idea why.
6 月 4 日，距离还有 48 天。阿卜迪去楼道上厕所时发现一名警察站在那里，并呼叫了增援。警察没索要贿赂。他放走了阿卜迪。阿卜迪不知道为什么。
June 8th, 44 days to go. Abdi tells me, apparently the police have started raiding during the day, which is a change. He avoided them because he was at class.
6 月 8 日，距离还有 44 天。阿卜迪告诉我，显然警察已经开始在白天进行突袭，这是一种改变。他因为上课躲过了他们。
June 15th, 37 days to go. Abdi hears on the radio that dozens of masked Al-Shabaab gunmen bombed the police station, stole its weapons, and went on a rampage in a town on the coast, killing at least 48 people. Abdi and Hassan brace for more police raids. July 7th, 15 days to go.
6 月 15 日，距离还有 37 天。阿卜迪在收音机里听说，几十名蒙面青年党武装分子炸毁了警察局，偷走了武器，并在沿海城镇进行暴乱，杀死了至少 48 人。阿卜迪和哈桑做好准备应对更多突袭。7 月 7 日，距离还有 15 天。
Leo, I'm telling you, they have chased me with machetes, with stones.
里奥，我告诉你，他们挥舞着大砍刀和石头追赶我。
Abdi, you're kidding.
阿卜迪，你开玩笑吧。
Yeah, it was only 12 hours ago.
是的，那是 12 小时前的事。
When Abdi and I speak, he's shaken up. He says he just tried to visit the mosque for the first time in weeks. It's right down the block.
当我和阿卜迪交谈时，他受到了惊吓。他说他只是尝试去几个星期没去的清真寺。它就在街区下方。
I was like only 10 steps away from my house, and then there's this, like, 50 armed young men. They were armed with machetes and with rocks in their hands. And they started chasing me and throwing those stones. And then I started running towards the mosque.
我离家只有 10 步远，然后有大约 50 名持枪年轻人。他们手里拿着大砍刀和石头。他们开始追赶我，向我扔石头。然后我开始向清真寺跑去。
The mob was a bunch of Kenyans attacking Somalis at random on the streets.
那群暴徒是一群在街上随机袭击索马里人的肯尼亚人。
Yeah, they caught up with us. They were beating these guys, and I couldn't look back.
是的，他们追上了我们。他们一直在殴打这些人，我不敢回头。
Oh, no.
噢，不。
I threw myself-- I threw myself into the mosque, and then somebody closed the gate. And the sheikh, clerk, he was like, please calm down. If these people want to kill us, I think we will all go to heaven. Because Allah says, if we die in the mosque, that's it. We're going straight to the heaven.
我冲进——我冲进清真寺，然后有人关上了大门。教长，职员，他说：请冷静。如果这些人想杀了我们，我想我们都会上天堂。因为真主说，如果我们死在清真寺里，就是这样。我们会直接上天堂。
Well, did you expect to die?
那么，你预料到自己会死吗？
I did.
我预料到了。
July 17th, five days to go. The woman sending him money from America wires cash for his interview fee-- $320. And then finally, July 21st, one day to go.
7 月 17 日，距离还有 5 天。那个从美国寄钱给他的女人汇来了面试费——320 美元。最后，7 月 21 日，还有一天。
It's actually not days. It's now hours left to my interview.
实际上不是天了。离我面试只剩下几个小时了。
10 hours and 53 minutes, to be precise. It's at 7:30 tomorrow morning.
精确地说，还有 10 小时 53 分钟。明天早上 7:30。
I'm not going to bed anymore. I'm not going to sleep. I am sure about that. Tomorrow is going to change my life. It's going to change my life to be the happiest person on Earth. It's going to change my life to be the most devastated man on Earth. So it's this too.
我再也不会上床了。我不会睡觉。我确定。明天将改变我的一生。它将改变我的一生，让我成为地球上最幸福的人。它将改变我的一生，让我成为地球上最沮丧的人。所以两种结果都有可能。
Tomorrow night, I'm coming back to this home, breaking everything, smashing everything right here, because I'm happy or I'm angry. In both situations, I'll break these things, I know. I will just give a punch into my laptop.
明晚，我会回到这个家，砸毁一切，破坏这里的所有东西，因为我很高兴或者我很愤怒。不管哪种情况，我都会砸这些东西，我知道。我会一拳打在笔记本电脑上。
I have to say, Abdi, I'm really excited for you. I'm just wishing you good luck with all my heart.
我必须说，阿卜迪，我真的为你感到兴奋。我衷心祝愿你好运。
Thank you.
谢谢。
I'm going to leave you and let you prepare, and can't wait to speak tomorrow.
我要让你去准备了，等不及明天和你交谈了。
I wish I will talk to you smiling, not really have that--
我希望明天和你交谈时我是笑着的，而不是带着那种——
I think you will be smiling. That's what I expect.
我想你会笑着的。我就是这么期待的。
Thank you. Thank you very much.
谢谢。非常感谢。
OK, so while I was brushing my teeth this morning, I got a text message, and it was from Abdi. Hi, very bad news. They gave me a red paper that said visa rejected. And yeah, we text messaged backwards and forwards. And the last message he sent to me, which was a few hours ago, was, this is my worst day on Earth.
好的，所以今天早上我在刷牙时，收到了一条短信，是阿卜迪发来的。你好，非常坏的消息。他们给了我一张红色纸条，说签证被拒绝了。是的，我们来回发短信。他发给我的最后一条消息，是几个小时前发的，是：这是我地球上最糟糕的一天。
I couldn't get hold of Abdi for a day. When I finally did talk to him, he walked me through what happened. Abdi arrived hours early. The waiting room was filled with other lottery winners. One by one, they were called in, and one by one, Abdi says, they came out grinning. Then Abdi's number was called. This was it, window 9.
我有整整一天没联系上阿卜迪。当我最终联系上他时，他带我回顾了发生的一切。阿卜迪提前几小时到达。候诊室里挤满了其他抽签获胜者。一个接一个地被叫进去，一个接一个地，阿卜迪说，他们都笑着走出来。然后阿卜迪的号码被叫到了。就是这儿，9 号窗口。
And there was this American lady. She was a black American, to be honest. I was really happy, because somebody already told me that the ladies are good than the men. So if a lady interviews you, you get the visa also. I was thinking, like, all right, man. You got it. So the first thing she said was, please, can you raise your right hand and swear that everything that you will say is the truth?
在那儿的是一位美国女士。老实说，她是一位黑人美国人。我真的很开心，因为已经有人告诉过我女士比男士好。所以如果女士面试你，你就能拿到签证。我心想：好吧，伙计。你拿到了。所以她说的第一件事是：拜托，你能举起右手发誓你所说的每一句话都是真话吗？
Abdi did, and he answered a few simple questions.
阿卜迪照做了，回答了几个简单的问题。
And then she was busy, writing something on her computer. I could feel that my legs were shivering. This is the moment. Man, this is the moment that you have been waiting for. And then she said, so tell me, where did you go to high school? And I said, Mogadishu, Somalia.
然后她就在忙着在电脑上写东西。我能感觉到我的腿在颤抖。就是这一刻。伙计，这是你一直在等待的时刻。然后她说：所以告诉我，你在哪里上的高中？我说：索马里摩加迪沙。
Where did you go to college, she asked. And he told her his university in Nairobi.
你在哪上的大学，她问。他告诉了她他在内罗毕的大学。
But she said the transcripts that you have here does not have a signature. Did you know that?
但她说：你这里的成绩单没有签字。你知道吗？
One of his school transcripts didn't have a signature. She took out a pink piece of paper and on the bottom, wrote two words-- "Missing Transcript." She handed it to Abdi and said, sorry, I can't give you the visa. I was looking into her eyes, like, please, come back to me and say, hey, I've changed my mind. Please, please, God. I need your help. I need luck today.
他的一张成绩单没签字。她拿出一张粉红色的纸，在底部写了两个词——“缺失成绩单”。她递给阿卜迪说：对不起，我不能给你签证。我凝视着她的眼睛，心里想：拜托，回心转意吧，说：嘿，我改变主意了。拜托，拜托，上帝。我需要你的帮助。我今天需要好运。
But the lady didn't change her mind. She picked up her microphone and called the next number. Dazed, Abdi walked outside and sat alone under a tree outside the embassy.
但那位女士没有改变主意。她拿起麦克风叫了下一个号码。神志恍惚的阿卜迪走出门，独自坐在大使馆外的一棵树下。
Because I needed to calm myself and bring myself together. I sat there. I was holding my head, and I was looking at this whole world as the worst place to live. I told myself, hey, are you rejected? Is this real, or am I dreaming? I thought it was like a dream. No, you can't do this. You can't do this.
因为我需要让自己冷静下来，调整心态。我坐在那里。我抱着头，看着整个世界，认为这是最糟糕的居住地。我告诉自己：嘿，你被拒绝了？这是真的，还是我在做梦？我以为这像是一场梦。不，你不能这样。你不能这样。
The embassy told him he could send them a signed transcript, if he wanted. But they told him not to come back to the embassy. They'd be in touch, maybe. Abdi sent the transcript, even though he was sure he'd missed his chance.
大使馆告诉他，如果愿意，他可以寄给他们一份签字的成绩单。但他们告诉他不要再来大使馆。他们会联系他的，也许吧。阿卜迪寄了成绩单，尽管他确信自己错失了机会。
Hello, this is Abdi Nor. It's the 1st of August, 2014. An email got into my inbox. It was Immigrant Visa Department at the US embassy. And it tells me, from our records, your document has been received, and your visa will be sent by tomorrow.
你好，我是阿卜迪·诺尔。现在是 2014 年 8 月 1 日。我的收件箱收到了一封邮件。是美国大使馆的移民签证部。它告诉我：根据我们的记录，您的文件已收到，您的签证将于明天寄出。
Oh, my god. This email made me jump off from my bed and hit my head onto the ceiling. It's issued. God, I just looked at it again. It's issued. What the hell is going on? It's issued. This big smile was on my face. I've never, ever had such a big smile-- never ever, ever, ever.
天哪。这封邮件让我从床上跳起来，头撞到了天花板。已签发。上帝，我再看了一遍。已签发。这到底是怎么回事？已签发。我脸上挂着巨大的笑容。我从来、从来没笑得这么开心过——从来没有，从来没有，从来没有。
Hey, you.
嘿，你。
Abdi. [LAUGHS] Oh, my god. How are you?
阿卜迪。[笑] 天哪。你好吗？
Leo.
里奥。
Are you recording this? First, please, before you say-- don't say anything first. Please be recording.
你在录音吗？首先，拜托，在你说话之前——先别说什么。请录音。
I'm recording, yeah.
我在录音，是的。
OK, great. How does it feel to be the owner of a US visa?
好的，太棒了。作为美国签证的拥有者感觉如何？
Mm-hmm. What was the question again? Sorry.
嗯。问题是什么来着？抱歉。
[LAUGHS] You're on a different planet.
[笑] 你在另一个星球上了。
Oh, yeah. What does it feel like to be a green card holder? It feels like the dream has just become real. I don't know what to say. It feels like I am not a refugee. No, this is not the refugee that was hiding from the police. I'm an American citizen.
哦，是的。作为绿卡持有者感觉如何？感觉梦想真的实现了。我不知道说什么好。感觉我不再是难民了。不，这不是那个躲避警察的难民。我是美国公民。
There was one thing about the approval of Abdi's visa that made us wonder. The day Abdi's visa was issued, before he heard the news, I had actually called the US embassy in Nairobi. I said I was a reporter doing a story about Abdi and that I was curious about how long their decision would take, because of my deadline. The woman I spoke to said she didn't know. For nine days, Abdi hadn't heard anything. Two hours after my call, he got the good news.
有一件事关于阿卜迪签证的批准让我们感到好奇。签证签发的当天，在阿卜迪听到消息之前，我实际上打电话给美国大使馆。我说我是记者，在报道阿卜迪的故事，我很好奇因为截止日期的原因，他们的决定需要多长时间。我和她交谈的那位女士说她不知道。九天了，阿卜迪什么消息也没收到。但在我打完电话两小时后，他得到了好消息。
We asked the State Department if my phone call influenced their decision about Abdi's visa, and they told us, quote, "The journalist's call played no role in the timing of the visa issuance. Any visa process coinciding with a press inquiry is merely a coincidence." I can't prove anything, but that is at odds with what the woman on the phone told me back when I initially called the embassy. She said that now that they knew I was doing a story about Abdi, they would try and expedite the process, even though I told her that wasn't why I was calling and that I was only asking for information.
我们询问国务院我的电话是否影响了他们对阿卜迪签证的决定，他们告诉我们，引用：“记者打电话对签证签发时间没有任何影响。任何签证流程与新闻问询的时间巧合纯属巧合。”我无法证明什么，但这与我最初打电话给大使馆时那个人在电话里说的有出入。她说现在他们知道我在报道阿卜迪的故事，他们会努力加快进程，尽管我告诉她那不是我打电话的原因，我只是在咨询信息。
We spoke with eight immigration lawyers, all experienced with the Diversity Visa Lottery, and they all said my call probably bumped Abdi's application to the top of the pile that day. And with the lottery, because they give out a finite number of visas by a hard deadline, that can be the difference between making it to the US, or not.
我们咨询了八位移民律师，他们都有多元化签证抽签的经验，他们都说我的电话可能那天把阿卜迪的申请推到了最上面。而对于抽签，因为签证数量有限且有严格的截止日期，这可能是能否到达美国的区别。
Leo Hornak, he's now at The Times of London, where he's the executive producer of the paper's new daily news podcast called, Stories of Our Times. The show launches next month.
里奥·霍纳克，他现在在《泰晤士报》伦敦分社，担任报纸新的每日新闻播客《时代故事》的执行制片人。该节目下个月上线。
On August 11th, 2014, Hassan took Abdi to Nairobi airport, and Abdi flew to America to live in a small town in Maine. The woman who had been supporting Abdi put him up with her family. He looked for work for a while, finally found a job installing installation. Lived in an apartment with three other Somali guys, mattresses on the floor. He wrote a book about his life, Call Me American. And then, three weeks ago--
2014 年 8 月 11 日，哈桑把阿卜迪送到内罗毕机场，阿卜迪飞往美国，住在缅因州的一个小镇。一直支持阿卜迪的那个女人把他安置在她家里。他找了一段时间工作，最终找到了一份安装绝缘材料的工作。和另外三个索马里小伙子住在一间公寓里，地板上铺着床垫。他写了一本关于自己生活的书《叫我美国人》。然后，三周前——
If all the candidates would remain standing, or stand if you can, and raise your right hand.
请所有候选人站立，如果可以的话，举起右手。
Abdi and 45 others in a sunshine-filled room in Maine raised their right hands. Abdi had tears in his eyes.
阿卜迪和缅因州一个洒满阳光的房间里的其他人举起了右手。阿卜迪眼中含着泪水。
And repeat after me. I hereby declare--
跟我重复一遍。我在此宣誓——
I hereby declare--
我在此宣誓——
--on oath--
——根据誓言——
--that I absolutely and entirely--
——我绝对且完全地——
--renounce and abjure--
——放弃并抵制——
--all allegiance and fidelity--
——所有效忠与忠诚——
--to any foreign prince--
——对任何外国君主——
--potentate--
——大权在握者——
--state or sovereignty--
——国家或主权——
OK, jumping ahead here.
快进一下。
That I will support and defend--
我将支持并捍卫——
--the Constitution of the United States--
——美利坚合众国宪法——
--against all enemies--
——反对所有敌人——
--foreign and domestic.
——外国和国内的。
Jumping ahead again. It all takes less than two minutes.
再次快进。这一切不到两分钟。
So help me, God.
上帝保佑我。
Congratulations. You are all United States citizens.
恭喜。你们都是美国公民了。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
There's also brief remarks from Senator Angus King.
参议员安格斯·金也有简短发言。
All of you who are immigrants or descendants of immigrants--
所有移民或移民后裔的你们——
A choir sings.
唱诗班在演唱。
(SINGING) And the rocket's red glare--
（演唱）火箭的红光——
Abdi leads everybody in the Pledge of Allegiance.
阿卜迪带领大家宣读效忠誓词。
-- and to the republic for which it stands--
——及其所代表的共和国——
And afterwards, I get a chance to talk to him.
之后，我得到了和他交谈的机会。
I think every second today was very, very moving. And I feel the transformation happening. I feel the change happening.
我想今天每一秒都非常、非常感人。我感觉到蜕变正在发生。我感觉到改变正在发生。
It's interesting. You actually do feel different now?
有趣的是。你真的感觉现在不同了？
I feel different, yes. Really, I feel different. I mean, I'm not that Abdi from yesterday. I can feel that. I can sense that, you know?
我感觉不同了，是的。真的，我感觉不同了。我的意思是，我不是昨天的那个阿卜迪了。我能感觉到。我能感觉得到，你懂吗？
Is the difference just that you feel safe?
差异仅仅是因为你感到安全了吗？
The difference is that I feel safe, but I also feel empowered. Empowered.
区别在于我感到安全，但也感到被授权了。被授权。
Able to vote, able to do anything any citizen can do, able to bring his mother over from Somalia. He's no longer worried that he'd be banned coming in and out of the country, or that the Trump administration will start to deport green card holders like him somehow. Finally, he said, his childhood nickname, Abdi the American, is matched by his nationality. It feels good.
能够投票，能够做任何公民能做的事，能够从索马里把母亲接过来。他不再担心进出这个国家会被禁止，或者特朗普政府会以某种方式开始驱逐像他这样的绿卡持有者。终于，他说，他儿时的绰号“美国人阿卜迪”与他的国籍相匹配了。感觉真好。
Who was I all these years? My life had been based on fighting for survival, and getting out of the war, and being threatened under-- it felt like I didn't have any rights at all as a displaced person, as a refugee, even as a green card holder or a resident in the United States. But now, I feel like it's like restarting. You know, when you play video games, if something happens and then you have a character was killed, you just have the power to go back and redo everything.
这些年来我是谁？我的生活是基于争取生存、逃离战争和受到威胁——感觉作为一个流离失所者、作为一个难民，甚至作为一个绿卡持有者或美国居民，我没有任何权利。但现在，感觉就像重启了。你知道，当你玩电子游戏时，如果发生什么事然后角色死了，你就有权回去重做一切。
One of the things I was so curious to ask Abdi about was, he had idealized America so much before he got here, in Kenya he used to say he loved America, so what was it like for him to actually live here? It seemed like no place could possibly live up to the way he'd felt about the United States. And he said, yeah, for all the safety, and opportunity, and freedom to speak and protest that he appreciates here, there were things about America that he was not prepared for.
我非常好奇想问阿卜迪的一件事是，他在来到这里之前把美国理想化了太多，在肯尼亚他曾说他爱美国，那么他真正生活在这里是什么感觉？看起来没有地方能像他想象中的美国那样好。他说，是的，对于他在这里所欣赏的所有安全、机会以及言论和抗议自由，有些关于美国的事情是他没准备好的。
At his first job here installing insulation, guys on the crew stole his hardhat, and his tools, and his winter coat, treated him like an outsider. And in a bigger way, the America that he liked seeing on television when he was growing up, an idealistic, united America, that's what he had expected to find.
在他在这里安装绝缘材料的第一份工作上，工友偷了他的安全帽、工具和冬大衣，像对待外人一样对待他。而在更大的层面，他从小在电视上看到的美国，一个理想化的、团结的美国，那是他所期望找到的。
But that America is not on the TV anymore. It's such a scary place, so divided, more like the Somali tribes. Some things that happen here really reminded me what started the Somali civil war, how people were not happy with each other, how we hated each other's tribe, and power and all that. And then the war that it started in 1991, 30 years old now. So I can't watch America go that path, you know? I can't. So the only thing that I can do is sort of not see the news to not break my heart. So America is such a confusing place.
但那个美国不再出现在电视上了。它是一个如此可怕的地方，如此分裂，更像索马里的部落。这里发生的一些事确实让我回想起是什么引发了索马里内战，人们如何对彼此不满，我们如何仇恨对方的部落、权力和所有这些。然后那场始于 1991 年的战争，现在 30 岁了。所以我不能看着美国走上那条路，你知道吗？我不能。所以我唯一能做的就是不看新闻，以免伤心。所以美国是一个如此令人困惑的地方。
Things are going well for him, though. He got certification as an interpreter, and that's his job nowadays. His brother, Hassan, has made it to Toronto with his wife and kids. And Abdi is attending college part time, studying politics. He doesn't just want to use his right to vote now that he's a citizen, he wants to run for office someday.
不过他现在过得很好。他获得了翻译认证，这是他现在的工作。他的哥哥哈桑已经带着妻子和孩子到了多伦多。阿卜迪正在兼职读大学，学习政治学。他现在不仅想在成为公民后行使投票权，还想有朝一日竞选公职。
[MUSIC - "BETTER" BY K'NAAN]
[音乐 - K'naan 的《Better》]
Well, the program was produced today by Brian Reed, Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, Julie Snyder, and Nancy Updike. And editing help for today's show from Joel Lovell. Production help from Noor Gill, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, and Matt Tierney.
好的，今天节目由布莱恩·里德、佐伊·蔡斯、肖恩·科尔、斯蒂芬妮·富、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、米基·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、罗宾·塞米恩、艾丽莎·希普、朱莉·斯奈德和南希·厄普代克制作。今天的节目编辑协助来自乔尔·洛弗尔。制作协助来自努尔·吉尔、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、斯托·尼尔森和马特·蒂尔尼。
Thanks to BBC Radio current affairs, Hugh Levinson and Brigitte Harney, BBC's Crossing Continents radio show, where a version of Leo's story first aired. Special thanks to Esther Sung at the National Immigration Law Center, also to PRI's The World, where Leo was a producer.
感谢 BBC 电台时事、休·莱文森和布里吉特·哈尼，BBC 的《跨越洲际》广播节目，莱奥的故事版本首次在那里播出。特别感谢国家移民法律中心的埃丝特·孙，也感谢 PRI 的《世界》，莱奥曾是那里的制片人。
Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站是 ThisAmericanLife.org。《美国生活》由 PRX，即公共广播交流中心分发给各公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he was giving me a ride home last night. And I reached out to the radio, which, of course, was playing our station. And before I could even touch the tuner, Torey is so hardcore Public Radio, he screeches the car over to the curve and tells me--
一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，他昨晚开车送我回家。我伸手去够收音机，当然，正在播放我们的电台。甚至在我碰到调谐器之前，托雷——他是如此硬核的公共广播迷——猛地把车停在路边，告诉我——
Boy, step out of my car. All right, call the police.
小伙子，下车。去，去报警。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[MUSIC - "BETTER" BY K'NAAN]
[音乐 - K'naan 的《Better》]